[Applause]
trailers are supposed to get you excited
and sometimes they do that by lying to
your face
you set me up no i didn't set you up you
lied to me
the marvel cinematic universe seems like
it's always able to stay one step ahead
of the audience and for an audience this
big that's impressive one way the series
keeps you guessing is through careful
misdirection in its movies mega hyped
trailers for instance the trailer for
thor ragnarok shows the god of thunder
walking around with both of his eyes
during the climactic final battle
against hella and asgard of course the
final product reveals that by that point
in the real story he's lost one of his
eyes entirely courtesy of his evil
half-sister he's never looked more like
his dearly departed dad in other
instances some scenes from marvel's
trailers are straight up missing in the
final movie like the infamous avengers
infinity war shot with all of the heroes
running toward the camera that's nowhere
in the actual film as one of the biggest
films the mcu has ever produced
spider-man no way home is no exception
to this rule and it obviously had some
secrets to hide now that the movie is
finally out let's look back at the
trailers to see all the times we were
deceived
no trust fire
when you don't want to reveal a big
surprise in a trailer sometimes the
easiest thing to do is just to cover it
up in post-production with so many
special effects shots in these movies
already it's not a huge ass to produce a
couple different versions of the same
scene in the marvel spidey 3 cool many
of the villains were clearly revealed
ahead of time but despite the early
tip-off sony and marvel clearly wanted
to preserve some of the who's going to
be in it mystique for later that appears
to be the case for the lizard from the
amazing spider-man 1 who was only sort
of revealed in the movie's first teaser
that footage included a scene where
peter stands in front of a magical
barrier and is startled by something
shadowy behind him many speculated that
the murky figure behind him could have
been the lizard in the actual movie no
guessing is required the lizard is in
full view in this very shot so it's
clear the sequence was darkened for the
trailer to avoid giving away the
identity of the attacker too soon of
course that all changed for the second
trailer which shows the lizard and full
view you stopped me once
you won't stop me again
fans immediately suspected something was
up when the second trailer included a
scene where tom holland's spider-man
leaps into action against electro lizard
and sandman it seemed weird that
holland's version would try to fight
three villains on his own especially
when it really seems like electro and
lizard are aiming pretty far away from
holland maybe they missed or was this
yet another trick obscuring the movie's
biggest secret the presence of peter 2
and peter 3.
it's the right answer things only got
more intriguing with the so-called
brazilian trailer league in that trailer
the statue of liberty fight sequence
goes on just a couple of seconds longer
than what we got in the united states
and it appears as though something
invisible hits lizard hard across the
face
again people wondered was this doctor
strange working his magic or was this a
hint that the final movie would show
another spider-man taking on an old foe
once again that's the right answer
people who see the movie years from now
won't remember just how much of a secret
it was that andrew garfield and toby
mcguire were back as their friendly
neighborhood spider-man in this movie
and trailer tricks like these helped
keep the secret up until the movie
itself revealed it
it was a valiant effort and even though
the biggest fans thought they had
figured out months in advance no one was
quite sure until those portals opened
and history was made
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you